les chinois ils entendent bien le mot
réciprocité ils savent ce que ça veut
dire aujourd'hui je vous donne un
exemple mais qui me que j'ai vécu
personnellement j'ai lancé le plus grand
appel d'offres dans ma région de bus
électriques trois mille bus électrique
le moins cher et et chinois mais est ce
que nos nos fournisseurs européens
peuvent candidater eux sur les marchés
de pékin ou de shanghai de réciprocité
comment l'un pour référence heureux mais
impose la réciprocité aux chinois abbas
est simple on ferme nos marchés
préférence européenne
ciblent le problème qu'on a c'est génial
ça consommateurs français vous allez
leur dire on peut plus acheter des
produits chinois bon marché mais ils
sont pour marcher artificiellement vous
savez mais il le certifie ciellement si
on faisait le bilan carbone de ces
produits qui ne respectent pas nos
normes sociales et environnementales
eh bien ces produits seraient beaucoup
plus cher un jean produits en chine il a
fait 70 mille kilomètres et le tissu a
été fait en inde il est parti parti en
chine il est revenu en france pas bon
voilà donc à assumer politiquement mais
il avait des français mais vis-à-vis des
français et vis-à-vis des européens je
pense qu'il ya un moment à quelque chose
à faire pour pour protéger nos
industries si vous voulez
réindustrialiser l'europe s'ils
voulaient réindustrialiser la france
vous n'y arriverez pas sans une vraie
taxe carbone aux frontières et sans une
vraie préférence européenne mais je les
fais un mot non pardon mais les bus
électriques j'ai pas choisi les moins
chers j'ai choisi j'ai choisi ceux qui
respectaient les normes sociales et
environnementales c'est à dire iveco et
heuliez est là les mecs si on veut avoir
la libre circulation au sein de l'union
européenne ça veut dire qu'il faut
protéger les frontières extérieures de
l'europe dans schengen il ya ce qu'on
appelle les points de passage autorisés
c'est donc les endroits où les migrants
qui se pressent aux portes de l'europe
pour des raisons économiques etc on
comprend qu'ils sont absolument
dramatiques
humainement mais l'europe a quand même
le droit c'est une puissance de choisir
qui elle accueille donc il ya des points
de passage obligé et normalement les
migrants doivent passer dans ses points
de passage ce que l'on vient d'apprendre
c'est que les chiffres sont hallucinants
mais c'est qu'il y a des dizaines de
millions de migrants qui ne passe pas
par ses points de passage autorisés
chaque année je crois que c'est de
l'ordre pas loin de 40 millions de
migrants cette année qui sont rentrés
dans l'europe sans passer par ces points
de passage autorisés c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont eu aucun contrôle et là on se
retrouve dans une situation où
effectivement on ne peut pas tenir nos
frontières la politique migratoire d'
emmanuel macron tournent à la bérézina
vous avez vu des chiffres qui ont été
publiés sur la france 270 mille titres
de séjour accordés cette année plus de
100000 réfute demandeur d'asile dont on
sait que la grande majorité sera
déboutée mais ne repartira pas donc on a
aujourd'hui une bérézina migratoires et
s'agissant l'italie s'agissant de ces
pays qui sont j'allais dire en première
ligne de la frontière de l'union
européenne il faut qui s'assume comme
étant en première ligne la grèce que je
suis allé visiter l'a fait la grèce ils
sont passés de 80 mille clandestins à
10000 en un an en mettant en mettant en
place des centres des centres ce qu'on
appelle les hotspots en anglais mais des
centres d'accueil et de d'enregistrement
et de régulation des migrants donc les
malheurs arrivent en 25 jours ont dit
600 demandeurs d'asile ou pas s'ils sont
pas demandeurs d'asile ils doivent
repartir